i was trolling on the moon one day
early what are you doing with the dirt
you just threw it all over yourself
fall down charlie yeah i fell down
[Applause]
sorry
that's everywhere john
but
that's what they say all right
i'll clean off the other i'm gonna clean
up the camera wait a second
let me get this
i just tried to blow off the dust tony
and it started at frame count number
four
okay bravo foreign
in 1968 astronauts on nasa's apollo 8
mission saw something that should have
been impossible in the last moments
before the lunar sunrise and sunset
every day they noticed a haze developing
on the horizon and then in the final few
seconds before the sun had risen or
fallen they saw bright bands of light
radiating out from the surface sharply
ascending out into the darkness
on earth we enjoyed these dazzling rays
twice a day as a result of our
atmosphere scattering sunlight but the
moon doesn't have an atmosphere there
are tiny amounts of some noble gases
like helium and aragon in the lunar
exosphere but for all purposes the space
above the surface of the moon is a
vacuum so where did these bands of light
come from
the answer doesn't lie with atmospheric
gases but instead
dust
the phenomenon observed by apollo
astronauts was caused by light passing
through and been scattered by layers of
microscopic lunar dust that had been
kicked off the surface of the moon for
the astronauts of the apollo missions
this would have been a beautiful thing
to witness but lunar dust has a dark
side after the end of the final apollo
mission gene cernan who was also the
last person to set foot on the moon said
the following i think dust is probably
one of our greatest inhibitors to a
nominal operation on the moon i think we
can overcome other psychological or
physical or mechanical problems except
from reports taken from the 17 apollo
missions as well as analysis of
spacesuits machinery and equipment after
they had returned to earth we now have a
very clear picture of just how damaging
lunar dust can be it significantly
obscured the vision of astronauts during
lunar landings it caused damage to
pre-existing machinery and objects on
the lunar surface when blown around by
the blast from landing spacecraft it
found its way into the lunar and command
modules not only causing eye nose and
lung irritation for the astronauts but
also covering screens damaging
electronic equipment and corroding
mechanical switches it affected and
sometimes completely broke watches
cameras rovers and experimental
equipment used on the surface of the
moon and found its way into every
crevice in the astronaut spacesuits hose
locks and zippers became difficult to
use the mobility of the suit was reduced
life support system displays were
difficult to see visors were scratched
electronics overheated and leaks in the
suit became more prevalent leading to
pressure losses and even when they tried
to remove the dust with vacuums and
brushes in the lunar module they were
never able to completely get rid of it
causing the spacesuits to become
gradually worse over time the astronauts
of apollo 17 spent the longest amount of
time outside of the lunar module but
only managed 22 hours of surface evas
during which almost irreparable damage
was done to the spacesuits had they
conducted more work on the lunar surface
the suits would have eventually been
rendered completely useless but 22 hours
is only a fraction of what would be
required for any future mission to the
moon in 2015 nasa laid out its space
technology road maps which identified
one key and hugely ambitious goal they
wanted their spacesuits to be able to
survive for 100 evas a total of 800
hours spent on the lunar surface almost
37 times the duration the apollo 17
astronauts spent outside more than any
other problem facing nasa or any other
space agency this could be the making or
breaking of a long-term outpost on the
surface of the moon but how do you begin
to extend the life of a spacesuit by
this much to get an answer we first need
to understand how lunar dust is formed
and why it sticks to anything it comes
in contact with unlike the surface of
the earth the surface of the moon is
under almost constant bombardment from
small and large meteorites some of them
only micrometers in diameter this rain
of debris causes parts of the lunar
rocks to break off creating a layer of
fine dust on the lunar surface
occasionally these micrometeorite
impacts hit with such force that they
can melt the minerals contained in the
soil turning them into glass lunar dust
is a mixture of super fine particles and
razor sharp glass that's also incredibly
dry there's no water in the soil or air
to clump the particles together and no
natural erosion through wind to blunt
the sharp edges
so this obviously does not mix well with
the intricate mechanisms of the lunar
spacesuits the dust is small enough to
get into almost any gap and thanks to
the shards of glass in the dust it can
easily scratch glass or metallic
surfaces but this is only the beginning
of the problem thanks to the lack of
atmosphere or magnetic field on the moon
lunar dust is exposed to every fraction
of radiation that's fired at us on the
side of the moon exposed to the sun
particles of dust are hit with x-ray and
ultraviolet radiation causing electrons
to be knocked off creating positive
charges on the surface of the dust
particles then on the side shielded from
the sun the opposite happens the
particles pick up electrons from solar
winds causing them to become negatively
charged these positive and negative
charges on the particles create
electrostatic potentials on the surface
of the moon reaching up to 20 volts on
the dayside and an astonishing minus
3800 volts on the night side when the
apollo 8 astronauts saw the beautiful
bands of light at sunset and sunrise
they weren't seeing the scattering of
radiation through atmospheric gases but
instead light passing through a column
of fine dust fired up from the surface
of the moon by electrostatic levitation
dust particles of like charges repel
each other and are repelled by the lunar
surface creating a fountain of sharp
micro dust that rises above the horizon
this is the same dust that apollo
astronauts walked through and kicked up
as they worked outside the lunar module
sticking to their suits in the same way
a statically charged balloon sticks to
your clothes charge is one of the main
reasons the dust is so annoying but it
could also be the way we could get rid
of it in 2021 as part of nasa's
breakthrough innovative and
game-changing idea challenge they tasked
university students from across the
world to come up with novel ways of
dealing with the lunar dust problem some
of the winning solutions included
conductive fibers inspired by chinchilla
hair an electrically charged brush that
could be powered by uv radiation and a
fabric for spacesuits that mimic the way
certain insects use hair-like structures
to collect and deposit pollen all of
these ideas use different ways to solve
the same problem but they share a common
approach using charge to either
passively or actively remove dust from
spacesuits at its simplest the problem
comes down to this how do you make the
outer layer of the spacesuit repel the
charged dust instead of attracting it
nasa came up with an elegant solution
instead of trying to redesign the outer
layer of the suit they decided to create
a system that could be easily integrated
into the pre-existing layers of fabric
and material found in the current
generation of spacesuits their idea was
to create a suit that could make its own
electrical current which would actively
eject dust acting like some sort of
energy shield and the first challenge
was choosing the conductive material
that the electrodes would be made out of
this method of dust ejection wasn't new
it was inspired by the electrodynamic
dust shield systems that had been used
by nasa since the late 1960s on things
like solar panels cameras and thermal
radiators but in almost all of these
cases the electrodes which were made out
of silver copper or some compound of
indium and tin were placed on rigid
fixed bodies a spacesuit is designed to
move the outer layer is made up of
segments of overlapping fabric that roll
over each other at joints when the
astronaut moves their arms or legs
so while the silver and copper
electrodes used in the pre-existing eds
systems might be excellent electrical
conductors with their low elasticity
they wouldn't survive the fatigue caused
by the constant flexing of the joints so
a new conductor was needed one that had
a high electrical conductivity but that
was flexible enough to withstand the
significant forces exerted on it during
extravehicular activities and the answer
was carbon nanotubes these are
cylindrical tubes of carbon atoms
stretching only a nanometer across with
walls one atom thick like a long thin
layer of graphene that's been rolled
into a tube carbon nanotubes are
incredibly strong with a considerably
higher tensile strength than copper
silver or gold and they have a very high
electrical conductivity carbon nanotubes
are also very light if you compare the
mass of different conductors required to
create an electrodynamic dust shield on
the knees elbows and boot areas of a
lunar spacesuit around 101 grams of
copper wire would be needed but if you
replace the copper with carbon nanotubes
you only need about 16 grams carbon
nanotubes are an excellent choice as
they provide high conductivity with low
mass while also being able to withstand
the 800 hours of evas required for
future lunar emissions so after settling
on carbon nanotubes it was then a matter
of finding a way of integrating these
nanotubes into the outer layer of the
spacesuits lunar spacesuits are made up
of up to 21 layers of material with an
outer ortho fabric layer composed of a
mixture of fibers like gore-tex and
kevlar the carbon nanotube electrodes
were made into yarns and then woven into
this outer layer in a longitudinal
direction to limit the tensile force
applied to the electrodes and they were
also spaced out from each other to
prevent electrical arcing the ortho
fabric in this outer layer acts as a
natural insulator but there is a chance
it could be broken down by high voltages
through testing it was found that the
ortho fabric could withstand up to 1200
volts so the dust removal system was
capped at around 1000 volts to prevent
dielectric breakdown of the insulating
material so how does the dust removal
system actually work the carbon nanotube
electrodes are first connected in
parallel and then activated by a
multi-phase alternating current at
voltages between 600 and 1000 volts and
very low currents around 3 milliamps
this sets up repeating waves of
electrical fields that move across the
outer surface of the spacesuit as they
interact with the charged dust particles
they add an additional repulsive force
to the particles based on coulomb
interactions repulsion due to the
interaction of two charged objects this
repulsive force is overall greater than
the gravitational and adhesive forces
which stick the particles to the suit
causing the particle to be ejected from
the ortho fabric but this also works for
uncharged particles that are stuck to
the suit when interacting with a
non-uniform electric field like in this
system uncharged dust can be repelled
through something called a
dielectrophoretic force overall the
electrical energy of the system is
transformed into mechanical energy as
the dust has kicked off the seuss
to test the system nasa constructed a
prototype knee joint with carbon
nanotubes woven into an outer ortho
fabric layer and used it to measure how
much of a lunar dust simulant was
removed
in different scenarios and what they
found was remarkable through analysis of
high-resolution images taken of the
fabric before and after activation of
the electrodes they saw that up to 96 of
the lunar dust simulant was removed by
the system this has enormous potential
for use as part of future moon missions
the dust removal system could be on
continuously during evas preventing any
dust from binding or it could be
manually activated when an astronaut
notices a large buildup of dust this
dust prevention technology may seem
trivial but this razor-sharp lunar dust
is a life-limiting threat to any future
moon colony this kind of simple
environmental effect that requires a
breakthrough material to overcome it is
the core of what makes engineering
exciting for me a relatively simple
solution that any new engineering
graduate could have helped develop and
go on to see their work land on the moon
seeing your work go from the lab to the
factory floor to the real world is one
of the most satisfying creative
processes in the world
engineering is a job for creatives with
a penchant for science and math and many
talented people are scared off from
engineering by the scary looking physics
but brilliant is here to help brilliant
has curated learning paths that would be
perfect for preparing you for an
education in engineering or if you are
simply an experienced engineer that
wants to brush up on your math skills
from courses on the fundamentals of math
to a curated course called college maths
brilliant is the perfect place to hone
your skills with easy to follow
interactive courses that will take you
from knowing nothing to having a
well-rounded understanding of the
building blocks of an engineering career
brilliant thought-provoking courses help
you see stem in a new way they'll guide
you from curiosity to mastery through
storytelling interactive challenges and
problems to solve you'll start by having
fun with their interactive puzzles and
visuals but with a little bit of
persistence and effort you'll be amazed
at what you can accomplish if you are
naturally curious want to build your
problem-solving skills want to develop
confidence in your analytical abilities
or like me find fulfillment in continual
lifelong learning then get brilliant to
learn something new every day if you are
looking for something else to watch
right now why not watch our previous
video on the air crash investigation of
the concorde or watch real science's
latest video about the world's most
deadly venom